it's on a highly successful trajectory
as well as being such an investigator
she also performed pioneering work that
really puts structures in the deep brain
on the map but also as being complex and
important for making us who we are
she studies the neural basis of learning
in action strategies relevant to
decision making making and breaking
habits effective state and brain
disorders and her talk title an ancient
brain system for modulating mood thank
you very much and many people have
talked about Pat and Laurie and I
remember the first time I saw you to
Amend met the family thank you for being
here and you all made such a deep
impression on me you said the whole
spirit of this place
you really did and well you Bob talked
about looking over the shoulder I didn't
have that experience my experience was
that every time
Lord you - every time I saw Pat kid
smile on his face
he was completely interested in everyone
and every time he saw someone it was as
though they were the center of attention
he asked what they were doing he made us
each one of us feel important as a human
being and as a scientist and the spirit
that the McGovern family Laurie
Pat
the family made was was formative in
this place and I think this spirit has
been shared by students and postdocs
undergraduates and actually the
Institute and many others who see this
place as special as full of energy it's
looking to the future as creative and as
at the same time as having some feel of
community of collegiality and of fury so
thank you Laurie and pet what I want to
talk with you about is how we make
decisions and how those decisions
influence our action this is actually
almost a miracle that we can intend to
do something and then do it and this
looping circuit is influenced highly
influenced by motivation and somehow
from that comes musical normative
thought and central to this whole
complex wonderfully dynamic action of
our brain our the deep structures of our
brain
you never know much about them today but
underneath this beautiful thinking cap
that we have in the neocortex our
structures
that are when this loop is broken
unfortunately responsible largely for
the extramural disorders
we've talked a little bit today about
Parkinson's disease but also nurses
yatris disorders this wasn't known until
a few years ago and one by one by one
these disorders were found to have some
component related to disorder in the
basal ganglia and especially in the
region I'll talk about called the
stratum and this same set of circuits
related to the basal ganglia are
responsible for addiction as they'll
come back to the effects of stress so
what is this system we're going to talk
about the fact that we assign values we
assign values to what we see to how we
act and eventually the neocortex
projecting down to these deep structures
I'm showing you the stratum these
structures through their outputs
influence the selection of the movements
or moods that we will have and the
system is beautifully modulated by the
dopamine system in the midbrain I'm sure
you all know about dopamine from
Parkinson's disease you may know it from
studies of schizophrenia and the thought
is that this region can send really
messing up with a saying are they it's
okay this system can send reinforcement
signals up to what am i doing
you've turned your bottom button and
then the top button without hitting this
is an intellectual feat of your small
proportion so there is the system and
let me say that the thought of the field
is that in the neocortex in neocortex we
find systems that circuits that have to
do with evaluating what to do then down
in the stratum we think is it worth
doing that circuit yes and then down
here in the midbrain the dopamine system
we asked the question of what
reinforcement should be given to this
system so the whole system tells us much
about as I say action and thoughts that
are going to come now deep in this
system lies this funny looking structure
it is seeing a slide that shows a cross
section through the stratum it's stained
for astral calling a very important your
transmitter in our bodies and brains and
it's partly funny looking because it has
these little little structures like
they're in there and they're there
and these we ended up calling serious
arms for straighter bodies and although
they look a bit funny what I'm going to
say is that in an amazing way
they turn out to be absolutely central
in this amazing pathway that influences
our actions now if you ask yourself help
him that'd be the very first thing that
we found was that if you look at the
brain of a monkey these regions you can
look at it with tracer methods and it
was the blue region here that especially
projected his reasons
and the reason I'm emphasizing this is
affari here is a skin of a human brain
in a person with depression and here
you'll see that same spot it's just in
front of the corpus callosum just like
this now if you look at someone who
craves cooking because he's a cook you
user it's the same region now if you
look this is an amazing study done in to
me at migrants who have come to Germany
to a city they become incredibly anxious
they've never really been in a city
they're so anxious that they end up
having to have therapy so these are
regions which beautifully might project
here and I'll show you some evidence for
that
No Deal wish I could see this better but
let me show you this system in a mouse
and I ready show you the system with the
the fighter brain on top the bottom the
brain on the bottom so the brain which
normally is here has been tilted like
hearing you'll see why here it is shown
from the back to the front and now we've
genetically labeled those two somos
neurons and what you can see is this
labyrinth made up of the stree sums that
show up as red labyrinths that fill
actually a fair amount of australia so
we now have a system that starts out
with this evaluation cortex somehow
targets some targets parts of it the
street zones and the spatial thing the
amazing thing about these little streams
is that they are the primary regions in
the stratum that have the privilege of
projecting directly to dopamine
containing neurons which are essential
for our normal blood motivation and
movement so the question that we came up
with is how do we deal with this system
how do we understand if it's a
decision-making system well what's the
decision man what controls it and so
what we decided to do was in animals try
to mimic one of the major categories of
abnormality shown by patients with
depression and anxiety
and here is here's what the system does
you see him here he's trying to decide
whether to prote approach or run away
you see his friends are already running
away and here he is and that is called
approach avoidance conflict
decision-making and as I said what am i
doing I'm so sorry
this system is tremendously present and
highly vulnerable in states of anxiety
and depression so what we did was we
decided to mimic that test as I said in
macaque monkeys in later mice and so we
said look at the amount of benefit if we
look at this in terms of cost benefit
mechanism here is the amount of benefit
y-axis the amount of cost and so these
are the decisions shown in these two
symbols made by the animals now if there
is a lot of benefit a very very small
cost the decisions will be down here if
there's a lot of costs very little
benefit the decisions will be over here
so what we could do was to find a
decision boundary between these two
behaviors and that was really important
because then what we could do is see
whether by manipulating the brain we
could change the behavior as well toward
a person more or avoiding war and so we
decided we would do that in that blue
area
and what we found and this is the work
of Kenichi a memoriam in her lab what we
found is that if we stimulated that blue
region was not a very strong increase in
avoidance the animals acted as though
what was coming in the future was less
good than it would have been had the
stimulation not been there and so they
were pessimistic so this phenomenon was
blocked by anxiolytics used to treat
people for example the effects of
diazepam
it was just dependently blocked this
entire effect there wasn't any effect on
our control approach approach test where
everything was good and then most
recently we've applied with the pizza
dolly lab at McLean Hospital this same
kind of task in humans normals and
people with depression and a really nice
thing is it in the study we've used
precisely the same stimuli as used in
monkeys and everything we could do we
did to make the situation similar to
what we've done in the experiments and
what you can see here in the title is
that this region which is right in front
of the corpus callosum you've seen it
over and over again this region was
active when the people felt that the
offer was versiv and when they actually
avoided so this gave us the first hint
of a commonality across many disorders
and healing could be seen in the tasks
that we were using
so this is an example of stimulus
stratum itself with similar methods and
you can see this decision boundary and
when the stimulation so here V avoids
grab the approaches in blue the decision
boundary and one returned the stimulus
on you may notice there's more red and
men/women stimulation read off again it
went back to the original decision
boundary we were shocked when we looked
at the monkey the next day he's just the
next day here's the stimulation off and
yet they're huge number of avoids there
is a simulation off a huge number of
avoids and again finally it began to go
on and on and tell in the third session
it normalized what that means is that
whatever we did when we applied micro
stimulation to the Strider mean you saw
it before in the Blue Zone we were
heading in effect that could last that
was very very surprising and interesting
and again this was was blocked by the
diazepam amen again there was no effect
in the benefit benefit test so we
wondered what this would be and why it
would be only present for these negative
effects so II asked could this be a
proxy for pessimistic decision made
for something related to depression and
anxiety and for that we really felt that
to get a better grasp of this we should
change to working on the mouse where the
methods is you hurdles aid our board
Vance and actually applicable in
applicable order veteran work straight
forward waving in the monkeys and so we
did that and here you can see actually a
blow-up of a seagull schism and what
we've been doing now mister driving that
at the system's level activity of the
system and the molecular specific
specificity of it so we turned to an old
old classic psychology type teammates
used four hundred fifty seventy years
and so what we did was to set up a very
simple cost-benefit test these mice love
chocolate so here's a little pot of pure
chocolate milk and the problem is were
paired it with very bright bright light
and may hate bright light on the other
hand if they would go this way the light
would be dim on the other hand the cost
would be the chocolate was really dilute
in fact we did parametric tests on how
much to dilute the chocolate and so a
normal Mouse will of course avoid the
light a lot most of the time and then
what we did was we look at this behavior
and then we looked at a microcircuit
which connected the neocortex to streets
homes
and there is this interneural system
that could change
we found the whole dynamics of this
circuit and let me show you how we found
it here's the normal situation the
normal Mouse will mainly avoid the light
and give up the high benefit so that way
and here's what happened when we
manipulated that circuit especially
those inner line what happened was
torence movement now the mice mainly ran
the other way they're running into
something they do not prefer something
they normally would run away from so
what we found in essence was that if
these little streets gnomes which I
showed you as red cells in the labyrinth
running for this right um if they were
turned on they were active then the mice
would approach the versa flight but if
they were turned off by our manipulation
which is updated then the mice avoided
the bright light and acted normally so
we asked ourselves now look if this is
some element related to something like
anxiety or depression or pessimism
that's like a state change it's like a
whole different faith you get up in the
morning and you just don't feel good
things don't seem so good I think
everybody has experienced that most
times we wake up happy full of optimism
like that learning but there are those
days and so could these three under that
circuit somehow be kinda like a switch
and could that's rich immediate or by
those three stones
which would be amazing a man we asked
now look if it is a state change then it
should be able to change it just by
experience without manipulating the
brain so here's what we did we started
with mice who had not yet stress and
then we applied to those same mice very
mild stress for two weeks once a day
they sat in a little tight cloth and I
think of it is going across the country
you know California to Boston Boston to
California but you've got a middle seat
right and by the time you done with that
flight you know you're cooked so then we
gave that gentle stress let me go back
there's a normal situation before the
stress now look how they change the
direction no thing was done to the
brains of these animals nothing the only
thing we did was to give two weeks of
this very mild
crying stress this experience experience
alone can switch the circuit dynamics
you heard from ed Boyden how important
dynamics is to these circuits and what
we found I won't go into is that
millisecond changes in their dynamics
are important for the switch the switch
based on experience so then we asked
well if we have the switch and it's
experience dependent is there any way to
rescue it to get rid of it to block the
effects of stress
and so bring her back what we did was to
manipulate that circuit and I hope that
you can see that that manipulation of
the circuit completely blocked the
effects of stress so we were very
excited about that we still are excited
about that because there are so many
conditions in partly in real life and
especially in disorders PTSD in which we
need to help have people reverse the
stress under which they are and we may
have found one circuit there may be many
which can handle this which is very
useful if we're thinking of eventual
therapy so so now what we turn to was
this last party circuit i've talking
about this these connections we've
talked about what's going on in here but
i told you that street zooms have that
are special in fact that they're just
about building urns it may not be the
only turns but they are the majority of
neurons apparently in stratum that can
project and therefore influence those
very very important dummy containing
urns which absolutely can change our
mood and our impulse to move so I'm
showing you here a little bit about what
the dopamine containing nucleus looks
like and now look at this isn't it
beautiful
these are the dopamine containing
neurons all stretched out in the
substantia [ __ ] pars compacta and the
white zone and pink
I mean the green and the white those
show the stray animal fibers that have
come all the way down from mr. item to
the dopamine containing a nucleus and
they probably synapse almost certainly
synapse on the dopamine containing arns
now I'd like to introduce what we've
called mystery some spheres on dopamine
okay and when we first saw this we saw
it first without but then with ed Boyden
suspension microscopy method and you'll
see these are like roses and their stems
and when you see the green and yellow
these are the dope these three some
fibers climbing up the stems making
contacts down here and finally reaching
the level of the roses so now what we're
doing is asking whether these threesomes
could turn on and off sets of dopamine
into neurons so they could perhaps
change these moods and so we're trying
very hard and it's difficult to modulate
parts of that circuit we're doing a
great deal of math engineering and never
thought our lab would be into that but
we are seriously and what you can see
over here but it's not blinking and it
should please wait anyway here yeah you
can see some blinking now we're doing
two-photon microscopy first at the level
of street songs we can see them now
because of the method
we used to manipulate them we can
actually see these little patches so we
can see the activity but Kelsey
remembers you so I've told you now about
three legs of this circuit and do you
see it runs all the way from bits of
cortex that we know are involved in
controlling mood motivation they're
abnormal in patients with many different
disorders related to these mood and
motivation systems running down through
here all the way to the reinforcement
system and let me tell you one more
thing if we look at this system and we
look at what chemicals could influence
the system the first thing to note is
here opioid receptors
you know the opioid problem in our
country in others these Express the
receptors that these drugs like fentanyl
are hitting this system ulcers vary and
I'm talking about reasons very rich in
particular kinds of serotonin receptors
that's a new funding well share telling
receptors of the kind I'm talking about
are targets of SSRIs which are given to
people who have problems among others
with anxiety
well what about cannabis before getting
going on opioids let's go all the way
and look at marijuana and stuff like
that and we just found that these
receptors yes what are heavily
interesting to bodies it's quite amazing
so in this system
I mean we're only at the start but look
at this list so this again makes us feel
this is only one set of circuits but
looks like it might be really important
so I want to close by coming back to the
spirit that's been created by the
McGovern family and like that coming
every time and looking in the face of
people I've seen it happened I've not
seen it but I've felt it as he looked at
me and the inspiration that he gave and
that you gave glory and now I know that
you have given me it's invaluable in my
life and it's invaluable in science here
so let me thank many people who have
through the time that you have started
this Institute and I'll tell you every
single one of these people everyone is
grateful to you thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much dr. gray bill do we
have a question from the audience
so that's very interesting so where does
cortisol the stress hormone where does
the stress hormone cortisol Siddons
isn't that interesting so we're not that
far I mean we have this sort of thing in
mind but we had to what we decided was
let's see if we have a circuit now we
can manipulate it and so we have we have
sort of a list and then on the very
first thing we actually are working on
is using two effectors in the room
and it's it could very well be or
ghrelin it's it's an excellent question
I I wish we could already into it but we
all try to and thank you